let the blame game begin President Biden
is still holding out hope for control of
the house as Democrats ramp up the intra
party fighting over why they lost key
seats to the Republicans the grand old
party is edging close to the magic
number of 218 for the majority and they
are still confident they will get there
but Biden seems to think the Dems May
eke out a win
well you know it's still alive
still alive as I've drawn an inside
straight but he's still alive and while
Biden hopes for a miracle the Democrats
are knifing each other
ousted New York house Democrat Sean
Patrick Maloney is calling out
Alexandria ocasio-cortez in the wake of
his embarrassing loss quote the last
time I ran into AOC we were beating her
endorsed candidate 2-1 in a primary and
I didn't see her one minute of these
midterms helping our house majority so
I'm not sure what kind of advice she has
but I'm sure she'll be generous with it
AOC firing right back by telling Maloney
to quote take some ownership
Democrats also lost seats in Florida and
strategist James Carville thinks it's
time to give up on the Sunshine State
we don't lose that bad in Mississippi I
I think that you know it's not as many
electoral votes but I think Democrats
might be better off looking hotter at
Mississippi than Florida I I don't know
that I'm just going to roof off the top
of my head but it's been very
frustrating
okay all right Dana I'll start with you
so Sean Patrick Maloney and I've been
interested in that race you know from
the get-go when he was in Paris raising
money on that balcony and I was do you
remember that Herald I was really upset
about that I'll follow him that closely
yeah well we did on the five you didn't
read the package that day or uh but you
probably weren't on that day but the
point is that he seems to be blaming AOC
it's not doing enough shouldn't she have
done more well I I have two ways of
answering this so Sean Patrick Maloney
when he got redistricted he basically
ousted a democratic incumbent and then
he lost to a Republican and he's head of
the Democratic Congressional committee
that's that's really saying something so
he lost it's an embarrassing loss he
also didn't do well across the board in
New York
um but probably because of how well Lee
zeldin did because they lost many seats
in Hudson River Valley and Long Island
now if I were him and I had just lost
instead of plotting my next political
move I'd take a few days off go for on
vacation maybe go back to Paris just
like take a minute before blaming other
people I understand that you're mad but
maybe that's something you do behind
closed doors because I thought aoc's
response to him was pretty good yeah now
she on her the other side of it is she
was complaining about raising money it
was 250 000 if you look at the
comparatively how much that that's a
drop in the bucket Nancy Pelosi can
raise that in 10 minutes but because AOC
is better at the small dollar donations
like Bernie Sanders is or even like a
Marjory Taylor green is that's her
strong point I would say this do you
remember when I was kept saying where is
the squad they were very quiet all
summer and all fall they were hiding
because they knew that they were going
to be blamed and now because they are
going to be emboldened if Biden runs
again or even if he doesn't the squad
people they're going to be real or what
do we calling them now the tyrants
they're going to be mad and they're
going to be very loud so be ready you
know yesterday Harold we talked about
the squad now having uh 10 people in it
and uh you know so they're going to be
stronger and louder than they were
before but to go back to Sean Patrick
Maloney he blamed hokel he said hokel
was one of the reasons that you know as
a governor at the top of the ticket she
should have been helping uh you know
some of the Congressional con candidates
in the Hudson Valley along with his race
as well I mean uh did she have a
responsibility
well she's the governor so she was at
the head of a ticket but look the the
fights today are happening everywhere
but the fight between Maloney and AOC
has been going on for a long long time I
don't think there's any love lost there
and just in the curve over the last 72
hours
um everybody needs to take a lesson from
this campaign uh Democrats probably
shouldn't overreact although it was a
pretty doggone good night for the
Democratic party they may end up winning
an outright majority in the U.S Senate
with an additional seat if the vote
counting uh as it's looking like it's
going could very well lead to that two
the problems in the country didn't go
away because Republicans didn't score
the victories they wanted or the size of
the victories they wanted
um what the country basically said was
we'd like voters voted for the poison
they knew and they didn't necessarily
vote for any new poison uh be it
democrat or republican look at the
governor as weak Florida was a great
night for DeSantis but Michigan was a
great night the Santas and Republicans
Michigan was a great night for Democrats
the governor was re-elected the Attorney
General was re-elected the Secretary of
State the FL that the house in the
Senate Michigan flip so a lot of stories
that have come out of this if I were
Republicans what I'd be most concerned
about is what is it that the country
didn't fully trust to give us the
ability and the capacity and the tools
to help fix these problems
and two they've got to sort out some of
their leadership issues with Mr McCarthy
and obviously at the top of the ticket
with the presidency and Democrats have
to figure out this was not an
affirmation for the squad or for their
Politics the country basically said
those who are too far left too far to
the right wherever you may sit in the TV
up the opposite way we want you coming
back to the middle here and if you don't
come back to the middle
um you know we're gonna we're gonna push
you out we can look at some of these
Governor's races where Republicans who
thought they were favored or having a
hard time we'll see what happens as the
votes are counted but I'm just glad that
the country and the voters I'm not
surprised but I'm I'm relieved and happy
though that everybody seems to have
accepted these outcomes and we'll now
sort through and try to accomp give some
commentary around it but Democrats they
didn't affirm the squad's message and
Republicans they didn't trust you to fix
the challenges so if I were in Congress
or the Senate I rolled my sleeves up and
figured how I work with the other side
to address some of these big problems
you know will the president said he was
looking forward to working with the
other side but is there anything in in
what he has done in the last two years
in indicates that he's actually willing
to do that no there's absolutely nothing
to suggest there will be any type of
bipartisan progress to be made going
forward I appreciate that Harold said
that this is not an affirmation of the
squad or the left's far left agenda you
know I do think that there's a bit this
week to hear from Democrats and
President Biden in particular where
there's an attempt to claim some victory
it's true that Republicans performed
below expectations but that's a bit like
the losing football team bragging about
covering Democrats saying they had some
type of Victory this week was well we
still lost power but we covered the
spread it is a bit of a loser's message
the bottom line is they no longer have
unilateral power in the federal
government we'll see we don't know we
don't know that for a fact we'll see
here in the next couple days that's a
fair caveat and as to Sean Patrick
million I would like to say this I don't
know what he expected
AOC is an Instagram influencer she is a
tick tock star she has no real influence
on policy and she had no real influence
on this politics and she happens to be
one of the biggest stars of the
democratic party along with two-time
losers Stacy Abrams and three-time loser
Beto O'Rourke don't forget Charlie Chris
and you know what's interesting about
that Greg I mean is that there she is as
will says the star in the Democrat Party
AOC and yet someone I think may have
been Maloney referred to her as a ghost
in Washington she wasn't fighting for
the majority
um and and I ran Statewide and I lost to
Andrew Cuomo I mean I didn't say a word
I just you know kind of licked my wounds
and just moved on I mean you shouldn't
be moaning about that stuff but you
expect the party to help you you know
it's what is interesting too is she has
completely ignored uh her constituents
and New Yorkers in general when it comes
to them saying they don't feel safe she
just did an interview
what did she say she didn't feel safe it
was an interview with Chris Wallace and
she feels that she heard like she can't
walk her dog at night and it's like you
know that's terrible for anybody but
it's terrible for everybody so now she
understands how her constituents and how
people feel on the subway and maybe
that'll give her a little bit more
compassion for the people that are
worried about crime everybody's blaming
everyone which means it's a pretty good
outcome right yeah Republicans are
blaming Trump Trump's blaming Fox
Maloney's playing AOC aoc's blaming
capitalism MSNBC is blaming white people
I blame Brian kilmead Dane is playing
climate change it's like the reading of
a will of a rich relative everybody left
a little disappointed and a little
pleased but get this you left life goes
on the bright side is no one is really
happy and the only reason why Joe seems
happy is that his expectations are lower
than Hunter's morals so it's easy for
him to kind of Roll Along to car about
Carvel you know rather than riding off
Florida why not ask what can be learned
from Florida right you know we have
states are basically like their own
little independent experiments right you
know you can see maybe if it rather than
the national that's what states are for
so with covid and the hurricanes
what what state did better in dealing
with emergencies you could say it's
Florida so what could you learn about a
state that doesn't have layers of
slow-moving bureaucracy versus you know
being a freedom leading State as opposed
to one that is relying on the tight
control of government that's something
that somebody can look in Florida and go
how do they do this this is interesting
rather than just saying eh that's their
California that's what they're what he's
basically saying is the way Republicans
have written off California they're
going to write off Florida or New York
but you know what you know we're coming
back I would say the right is coming
back in New York and you know we have a
lot to thank to zeldin for that
and that's all I gotta say judge no
that's enough coming up next President
Biden over season ramping up his global
warming Hysteria by warning the world of
climate hell
I want to Brian Kilmeade I want you to
do me a favor I want you to click to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
this is the only way that I know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming your way on
Fox you can get it all here on YouTube
so subscribe right now